I'm going to do something here that I've
never done before
um Eduardo I want you to step in because
you're a neutral Observer here and I
want you to do
um I know there's more
to come with this gentleman Kevin Neal
and look at the page yeah Kevin Nealon
um
I want you to do
give us like the forensics on what's
happened here so far like an autopsy
seriously give us Sonia okay no no I
just I want because sona's gonna like
she's like says
you know I think it's all Conan's fault
do me a favor and tell me what you think
has happened here so far today A
beautiful train wreck this is a mess
Eduardo this is beautiful wait a minute
this is not the Eduardo I know
Eduardo right am I right about this I
mean it's like when you're going down
the freeway and the accident happened on
the other side of the freeway and you
just can't take your eyes off you know
you shouldn't be looking but you just
can't take your eyes off see well you
know this is which one of us can't you
take your eyes off of I mean between
your straw bits yeah because
strawberries are getting me every single
time I'm gonna just blame you both of
you are I have children don't be so
defensive yeah wait a minute Connie
you're defensive I have tried several
times to bring us back to a a no you
haven't no not at all
I didn't say I tried hard okay
you're the mom with twins I'm totally
concerned about my cholesterol
sauna it's his show he should be in
control you're right this is a this is
an absolute Jackson Pollock there's
paint splattered everywhere but
someone's going to offer to pay 35
million dollars for this let's go back
and try it again and be serious okay how
are you Kevin how you doing I'm fine
thank you yeah you know what if you want
me to ask you that question don't you
which question the one how are you no
because you asked me that I know you
want to hear it why did you do that
right away
immediately you did that how are you you
did that no I haven't I did not do it
you're
um nothing I've done to see if there's
anything here that I can ask you but
it's all a waste of time
because there's no point with him the
funniest part of my day today is when
Maddie handed me notes for Kevin Nealon
and I thought notes for Kevin Nealon
that's like oh
here's uh here's some sample questions
that you could ask Charles Manson and
he'd be like too many down I'll catch
you man with the Sasquatch on the half
shell yeah so anyway you were born in
Minnesota keep it
I'm coming action lifestyle
so that's what I'm dealing with I'm
dealing with a total you are a random
ionized uh molecule zipping around I
don't know what to do let me give you
two days October 25 October 27th October
25 would be the release of the book yeah
what's the book called It's called I
exaggerate my brushes with Fame yeah
hardcover
available everywhere yes you could
pre-order it now as a matter of fact
well I wouldn't and there's also signed
editions go ahead I've got a free one
okay when is the hiking show premiere
October 27 2022 you get to see
um amateur drone shots uh Conan O'Brien
and Kevin Nealon taken from I think 35
000 feet so if you can spot us God bless
you and if you stick around the the
drone crashes because it's operated by
the star of the show which is absurd I
don't know why you don't have someone
helping you why don't you have someone
helping you I I say the same thing about
you why don't you have some help ask for
help you need help I'm surrounded by
help no no what do you mean like Eduardo
said he considers you a a wreck a car
wreck no no
he was talking about you right Eduardo
not quite what I meant what do you want
from these conversations okay that's
more like I want to hear from you I want
to get down to it okay and finally
you've cracked the shell a little bit
okay what do you want from our
friendship because we are friends I do
care about you I want more time with you
it's like every time I call you to go
for a hike or a walk no you call me at
the last minute well but you you have to
admit you do contact me as you're
walking past my house why not even give
me a half hour's head notice or the
night before I'm spontaneous that's how
life is you live in the moment if you're
living in the moment you can't plan
ahead
how do you make restaurant reservations
I have somebody else do it for me
they don't live in the moment
so you can only live in the moment what
if you had your lovely wife uh make the
plan and then you could I could be
standing out front ready to go on the
walk but there's the problem we both
live in the moment that's why we're
right for each other if you lived in the
moment you would be available
and sometimes you tell me you're not
home and I walk by I see your truck out
there
that hayseed truck that you drive I
drive it well you know that I clean
pools on the side I've got a lot of
things going on I've got a lot of
businesses going what was the first job
you ever had I remember as a male model
when I was 16. is that true yeah it was
very good looking when I was young very
good looking what happened
seriously what happened uh I think my
first job was uh I was a camp counselor
and I was like oh that's something I
think that's a good job I didn't love it
I didn't love it a lot of standing in
the sun which isn't good for me it
smelled like someone was cooking bacon
uh and uh looking after these kids uh
who seemed ungrateful what was the last
surgery you've ever had
[Music]
seriously uh I think I'm on my
appendicitis
my appendix was removed probably
1975. something like that I was seven
when I had mine removed I lived in
Germany at the time you said Germany
yeah JFK removed it
stay still and oh yeah I will uh remove
this appendix when I uh returned to the
car uh Caroline was gone okay I don't
know what you're talking about
I don't remember that album the first uh
family yep yeah that's what they said on
there I'll go down to the end of the
dock we'll meet you for water skis
so I was in a German Hospital you're
thinking of Von meter is that correct
the famous one yeah okay so I was seven
and uh unusable
side pain if anyone's interested and
they took me to a German hospital and
back then they didn't have anesthesia
they gave you ether they put a mask on
yeah and they breathe in The Ether and I
could still
remember the smell of that how horrible
it was yeah and I woke up a couple hours
later and I was in bed and they had
newspapers under me because I was still
kind of like oozing fluid and blood
do you guys have
ordering lunch or anything no I don't no
we're not getting you lunch for that
story
so you had your uh appendix removed and
they gave you ether powerful ether you
know a side effect of ether is a
long-term inability to complete a
thought did you know that I had no idea
yeah but I will tell you this
um I went for a physical about a month
ago who cares about the time schedule
you know every comic goes you know the
other day or yesterday I did on Tuesday
last year nobody cares about the date
so getting back to what I was going to
say before you interrupted me
um I went to get a physical and you know
when you go to physical you sit in the
doctor's office
and he goes to the computer about all
the uh ailments you've had over the
years and surgeries I'm telling you I
sat there for like a half hour he's
going okay you had uh torn bicep muscles
hernia appendicitis you had your hip
replaced you had a benign tumor in your
neck and after a while I'm going okay
that's enough all right can we just stop
right there you've had a lot to be
honest to be honest you've had a lot of
stuff a lot of Health scares happened to
you not not I got one or two Health
scares uh because I was a mountain
climber
rock climber solo free solo and um and
then he goes okay well let's just check
the medications you're taking okay same
thing like a long list and I'm thinking
how am I still alive yeah
take a break we'll be right back no no
we're not taking a break
you've had a lot of Health scares you
have mostly from you that's not true
that's not true I'm gonna keep you on
track you've you've brushed up with
mortality many times I have and there is
thicker no that you just get sick a lot
you didn't take any risks and you're not
a mountain climber you just your body's
falling apart all the time and then they
Stitch you back together I thought he
was serious no he's not a mountain
climber nothing he says Eduardo did you
know that he was lying I thought he was
about no you're not a [ __ ] mountain
climber why do you expose me like this
why are you exposing the embarrassment
people are listening to this and I think
of myself as a journalist uh someone
who's here to get the truth does anybody
else think of you as a journalist not
yet but in time uh when I go to
journalism School you um again you don't
need to refer to them I'm gonna tear up
these notes because it's ridiculous save
those for John lovers you know
jealous
okay acting to keep up with lovetts not
really he did call me a couple months
ago because we haven't talked to him
Yang they're calling you to say hi
that's good oh that's that was Schneider
that was Rob Schneider yeah I don't do
Impressions really so Lovett's called
you as Schneider no yeah okay sorry
to be say something it wasn't quite true
um who do you hope calls you uh who are
you like disappointed that doesn't call
you
not to ask for a hike as I walk around
your house but just to say hi how you
doing I do a lot lately I'll call people
out of the blue and say hey man I'm just
thinking about you that's nice yeah I do
that sometimes when uh I do I do when
I'm driving actually when I'm driving in
La is a really nice time to just say you
know what I haven't talked to this
person for a while and uh and say stop
sipping a drink every time I'm real it's
got a male straw it's a sabotage don't
you guys have any real straws every time
I try to be real he does a big
exaggerated slurpose coffee yeah we see
you've been doing nothing much it's a
mental straw why don't you have
something like that's not metal here
because we're trying to save the
environment well what about the metal
the metal can always be melted down
later on it needs to make a bullet so
don't worry about it what happens when
they melt the metal it goes into the air
the toxicity I don't know what you're
talking about and you know what frankly
you don't know what you're doing when
was the last time you wore a tux
I won't do it anymore
at some point one time think of yourself
as the referee you can step in at some
point and you can say enough okay we're
almost there I mean because this is
you're you're not just damaging is that
is it watching me is Eduardo also your
driver no what are you talking about
what I mean how could you have people on
the show there's nothing to do what do
you what do you mean
Eduardo set up this studio this
beautiful Studio he is a sound
technician engineer he did a beautiful
job constructing this place that works
beautifully so that we could it's not a
big deal so that we could conduct
uh we could conduct cohesive coherent
interviews let's try one right now let's
try we've tried I've tried you haven't
tried I've been trying since I got here
we should put you guys on the clock see
if you could do like three minutes
straight yeah
and seriously Kevin will you try I'm not
I'll have to try I will do okay let's
try it you're gonna set a clock
you never
you've known a lot of funny people Kevin
uh tell me who were some of you who do
you think was the all-time funniest I
mean I know that uh you have a very
close to Gary shanling when you got to
meet Carson uh and uh Steve Martin who's
your all-time one person at the very top
first of all thank you for your question
foreign
it's funny you should ask that because I
was just thinking about a joke that
Stanley Myron Handelman did I used to
follow this comic Stanley Myron
Handelman and uh I you know so many
Comics growing up I mean comedians
growing up I would like they would
become my favorites for like a week but
you know everyone from uh
today man I love this guy Todd King is
that his name Don King I'll fight
promoter
please uh there's somebody are you okay
yeah I'm thinking about these funny
comics because they really influenced me
Albert Brooks Steve Burton sure is it
bartner Martin it's Martin Steve Martin
you're friends with him Steve Barton
Alan King
who's the king
this guy Alan King makes me laugh a lot
laughing right now about him no you're
not you're having a nervous breakdown
and you're saying you're laughing about
no no no go don't go there okay you just
went there you went there you attacked
me
you you attacked me I asked you a very
soon
I'm not kidding ladies and gentlemen
because you're crying I couldn't do it
for three little minutes you attacked me
you actually had me at that was a great
question that's when I lost it you you
you you can't do it I did it I tried
what you did it you're a mess you
attacked me
you came at me you came at me hard
this is unusable
energy let's pick up where we left off
how much time how much time all right
let's finish the 90 seconds crying he
has tears around himself that's not
tears I'm allergic to you
now listen let's get back to it
how many people how many comments do you
need me to name I don't know I just was
curious if I told her that she stood out
yeah I'm gonna say for you it was Steve
Martin any uh Kaufman and Steve Martin
yeah these are your favorites and you
don't even know who they are he's
attacking me again he's attacking me
what's your favorite we try to I like
Bill stepman what is that his name I
don't know Eduardo who couldn't do it
one to one
me
you just can't contain himself he's
trying to say this you're one of my
favorites of all time well thank you
very much I don't mean that I absolutely
mean that because you have such an agile
mind I'm being serious I I I you have
such an agile mind your soul your rhythm
is so unpredictable and hilarious uh
that I I think you're one of the
all-time greats I really do
appreciate that
um you do well too you do all right for
yourself I love I love your style I mean
you know I I I'm I'll be honest with you
I'm surprised and I'm not attacking you
you're surprised at what I'm not
attacking back you're surprised at what
I'm not gonna pounce it to you okay uh
I'm just surprised and happy for you
yeah go ahead you surprised about one
that's far go ahead ask you maybe
you you followed up me saying that I
think you're one of the all-time
Brothers we keep saying that you're
surprised
can I finish sure
you have become something that is
unbelievable
seriously I don't know how you do it you
become this legend of
I won't say mediocrity because I knew
you think I would say that
exactly it's more than that not a lot
more but it's
and you know I love you right so much I
don't I don't know now I'm starting to
almost cry come on look at this I just I
love you almost
surprised you're surprised that I've
made it this place don't attack me don't
attack me please
but you're making it you're cynical
you're cynical in here you're full of
hate
thank you
look let's let me just continue how much
time in the world oh my God this will be
the tiebreaker if you guys can end I
can't believe that you are making I'm
gonna end first I cannot believe it you
have such a style you are so smart and
you're so excited I have no surgeries
you have little problems at all in life
and you've really made a lot of yourself
I think so
and I love you I can't say that enough
and I'm really you influenced Me growing
up you asked me about a comic you it
might influence you growing up when you
are older than I why are you laughing me
off like that what is he constantly
so when you were a young boy in Germany
I didn't say when I was a kid oh okay
you influenced me when I walked in here
today do you no the way you have
everything together I thought cones
really got us stuck together because why
you took life seriously
and you planned for the future
and I'm sure you had big plans some of
them maybe didn't work out I'm serious
I'm trying to be serious okay okay and
[Music]
um
why don't you tell me about yourself
well I'd love to but we're out of time
no I really yeah we're out of time
because
um
you uh
and I I'll take some responsibility but
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
take 25 yeah I'm gonna take 25 25 out of
30 is not bad no not out of 30. I'm out
of how many 100 100
I'll take a word of responsibility that
you are a little bit of catnip to me I
do react to Kevin that way I get a
little giddy but uh you are a not just a
Wild Mustang that can't be tamed you're
a Mustang that's been drugged
caffeinated and had a rocket shoved up
its ass and then two out of those three
are correct
caffeinated I don't know about
caffeinated
but um
I'm going to ask everyone who listened
to this entire first of all I think
there's got to be a prize for anyone
that listened to the whole thing I don't
know why would you say that because even
on the outro you cannot be serious and I
want to be quite serious I think there
should be some kind of uh maybe even a
cash prize for anyone who can prove
why do you do that in the middle of a
sentence and then uh
and and if anyone sees a continuity here
that I don't see or a thread that I
don't see I'd love to hear about it that
is your fault you are the captain of the
ship why do you let things get out of
control said the torpedo
[Laughter]
a torpedo yelling at the captain
yeah but a torpedo makes changes you're
a captain who doesn't make changes and
that's the problem you're you're going
off course
okay you you apply please take some
blame for this yeah I did I took 25 well
out of 30 that's not bad